This kind of reflection model is called Toon Shading, or Cel Shading, or
sometimes Posterization. Toon is short for cartoon. Cel is short for celuloid,
the material for the transparent sheets that are used when animation is drawn
by hand. There are all sorts of variations for this type of rendering. For
example, you can change colors based on the shading level and get more
elaborate effects. In this rendering, a separate image processing shader is
used to detect the edges of the object, and outline them. This type of
illumination model is one example of what's called Non Photorealistic
Rendering, or NPR for short. Photorealistic means "looks like a photo." If you
think about it, there is a nearly infinite number of ways to draw things that
do not look realistic. The running joke is that we've been doing
non-photorealistic rendering on computers for decades, since realism is hard to
achieve. The way I see it is that non-photorealistic rendering has an intent
behind it. Just as we assign different fonts to text to convey a different
impression, NPR is a choice we can make about 3D rendering. Scott McCloud and
his book, Understanding Comics, talks about amplification through
simplification. The idea is that by displaying only the relevant pieces of
information, you strengthen your message. For example, an automobile owner
manual usually has simplified drawings instead of photos. Non-photorealistic
techniques often try to convey information in a more sketchy or artistic way.
For example, a sketchy look can let the viewer know that the result they're
looking at is in just an early stage of design.